i want to kind of stay here on the
family thing we talked about your uncle
russell
um
it i mean if you these are one of those
things where if anything's googleable i
don't mind asking it right so if you
google
russell galbit you can see that the guy
is worth something with a b
next to it something in the billionaire
category not many uncles you know i have
an uncle's doing well off
yeah like you know who sends me 100
bucks on my birthday thanks
you know it's not a billionaire but
what i want to know is the lessons
you've learned from your billionaire
uncle meaning
you started working from him probably
when you were 16 15. you were sweeping
floors doing whatever
now you're 41
you're
married family man kids
i want to kind of hear the advice he
gave to you when you were 16
maybe the advice when he gave when you
were 26 and now that you're uh um
you know an adult with a family like
what kind of advice and what kind of
um tutelage has this billionaire great
uncle of yours given you
so his thing which hasn't changed in 20
years and won't change when he's
20 years old now is he is a statement
where she says don't lose money
and i'm telling you that is how he
thinks that's how he's always preached
so
although it sounds
pretty simple yeah who wants to lose
money but
since i was 16 and i did construction
form in a nursing home when i was 17 and
worked from inside a hotel for my first
time when i was 21 and moved to atlanta
to sell condos for him i always knew the
one thing he said me was don't lose
money so whether i was
you know doing construction or i was
checking some on the front desk or
selling a unit
i always thought about what he meant was
just don't lose money
and that's how he still thinks today so
you know he started out as a self-made
guy um you know very humble beginnings
my beach he was a fourth child of a of a
you know very
um not wealthy working hard jewish
family and you know so he actually grew
up being the youngest with no money how
to make money so he's done it on his own
and he has the same mindset as he did
then and now i'll tell you when i was
22 years old
him and i went to a meeting at a
restaurant
and it was in bell harbor mall where you
pull in you take a ticket you park the
car
if you eat you get a stamp it's free
parking
anyway i'm 22 years old i've got maybe
three suits they're all great
you know i look at them i clean them i
make sure they're they're good for the
week and i remember we had a lunch
meeting we get inside his car
and he forgot to get the stamp on the
ticket which is fine it's pouring rain
this is in june of miami and it is
literally a hurricane coming down
he looks at me and he says to me oh my
god we didn't do the stamp but i it's
like a dollar fifty to get out i go
yeah i think we both forgot but like
it's it's fine it's a dollar fifty is
like are you out of your mind go get the
stamp
so literally that suit that i
look at and care about ran in the rain
got the stamped because in his mind is
why would i spend a dollar fifty
if literally it's free so there's
certain things that we've done through
our lives and you know him and i've
worked together for now 20
it's not a kid so called 23 24 years
and all the business i do are partners
in and you know he he's going to trust
me along the way and we have a fabulous
relationship but
those are things that he always morphed
and by the way the same guy today yeah
if i was with him right now in that same
spot we do the exact same thing yeah i
love that because you would think dude
you're a freaking billionaire what the
hell do you care but it's the mindset
that you have to have
um
that gets you to become it's the valuing
money it's valuing the work ethic it's
the we don't lose money
yes i get that it's raining but go get
the free valet ticket stamped and it's
it's it's deeper than just getting the
ticket stamped there's the principle of
no this is you know i just spent x
amount of money at this meal i'm getting
my free parking yeah now the truth is
he'll look at me today and i'm not going
to get the stamp i'm fine with it like
i'll just give you like ten dollars and
i'm out but he'll say are you out of
your mind so you know i guess
he he's a dynamic amazing person he's
the smartest person i think i know
um in business and just you know just in
life and
just watching really created kind of the
person i grew to be like you mentioned
when i was 16 to now 41 right well like
i've been watching him some 16 years old
right so we think the same we do things
the same that's why if we do business
literally if i said i'm doing a deal
tomorrow he won't even ask me to see a
number i'll just go i get it if you're
in i'm in there's a trust fund and he
knows it'll work so i don't have to do a
presentation or sell it to him it's like
look we're doing a deal we just put an x
i got this now go to me go ahead keith
do your thing so we have a beautiful
trust um and to your point being family
is not always easy
but you know you're also as good as your
last deal and like i said before you
know when i do business i don't stop
till i'm successful so it's not like i'm
a nephew who's lost 10 deals and made
one he like he knows i'm doing something
he's a tracker i win so shout out to
russell galbet by the way what's his
instagram
i think it's actually russell does he
have an instagram he does wow how many
followers do you think he has
i don't know he should have a lot more
best guess how many followers you think
he has i mean he's kind of a private guy
he's not really on social media much i
would say
let's give him a thousand
[Music]
you